AS WE JUMP TO OUR NEXT GAME IT'S
TIME FOR STONED, DRUNK, OR
PREGNANT.
I'M GOING TO READ A TWEET WITH A
HASHTAG.
FOR 250 POINTS, YOU HAVE TO TELL
ME IF THE HASHTAG IS #STONED,
#DRUNK, OR #PREGNANT.
I ACCIDENTALLY JUST TOOK MY
SHIRT OFF AND THREW IT AWAY.
YES, KURT.
>> PREGNANT.
PREGNANT, PREGNANT, PREGNANT.
>> THE ANSWER IS STONED, STONED.
SO NO POINTS.
>> THAT'S FINE.
THE JOKE TO ME WAS WORTH IT.
>> PREGNANT IS LIKE BEING BABY
STONED, RIGHT?
>> I SAID IT WAS JUST LIKE CHECK
OUT MY BELLY!
I DON'T NEED IT ANYMORE!
( BLEEP ) BORED.
I'M ABOUT TO GET WASTED.
GRACE.
>> PREGNANT, DRUNK PREGNANT.
( LAUGHTER )
( APPLAUSE ).
>> ARE YOU GOING WITH DRUNK OR
PREGNANT GIKNOW, I'M GOING TO GO
WITH THE CLASSY PREGNANT.
>> YES, FORTUNATELY, THAT'S
PREGNANT, GETTING WASTED.
WELL DONE.
>> WHAT!
IT'S TEEN MOM AMBER, RIGHT,
MAYBE?
>> A WHOLE NEW KIND OF AMBER
ALERT.
( LAUGHTER )
DON'T LET THAT WOMAN DRINK WITH
A BABY IN HER BODY.
>> THERE WAS ALREADY AN AMBER
VAN DORN.
THAT MEANS SHE WAS BLOCKEDDED
AND HAD TO MAKE A NEW ONE.
>> NO, NO, NO, SHE GOT REALLY
PREGNANT ONE NIGHT AND DELETED
HER FIRST ACCOUNT.
( APPLAUSE )
I'M NOT SURE WHAT THIS NEXT ONE
MINES MOOENS BUT I'M DELIGHTED
BY IT.
JUST AN EMOTIONAL ASS MOMENT.
LET THAT SOAK IN.
YES, KURT.
>> STOAPPED.
>> NO, THAT IS DRUNK.
>> ARE YOU JOKING!
>> VERY EMOTIONAL--
>> LIKE, I JUST HAD AN EMOTIONAL
ASS MOMENT.
( LAUGHTER ).
>> IS THAT A UTERUS, OR IS THAT
A BIRD WITH GIANT BALLS?
>> YES, I THINK--